[Música]
está de pie en el arco cuando de repente
siente un picor intenso detrás de la
cabeza
todos hemos experimentado la molestia de
un picor inconveniente pero alguna vez
ha reflexionado sobre Por qué sentimos
picor la persona promedio experimenta
docenas de picores individuales cada día
pueden ser activados por todo tipo de
cosas incluidas reacciones alérgicas
sequedad y algunas enfermedades y luego
están los picores misteriosos que
aparecen sin causa en absoluto o
simplemente si se habla de picores se
está rascando la cabeza en este momento
no veamos una de las fuentes más comunes
las picaduras de insectos cuando un
mosquito lo pica libera un compuesto en
su cuerpo llamado anticoagulante que
evita que la sangre coagule ese
compuesto al que somos ligeramente
desencadena la liberación de histamina
una sustancia química que hincha
nuestros capilares esto permite un mayor
flujo sanguíneo que acelera la respuesta
inmune a la amenaza percibida eso
explica la hinchazón y por la misma
razón el polen puede hacer que se
hinchen los ojos la histamina también
activa los nervios Implicados En el
picor razón por la que picaduras de
insectos hacen rascarnos pero la
sensación de picor en Sí todavía no se
entiende completamente de hecho gran
parte de lo que sabemos viene de
estudiar la mecánica del picor en
ratones Los investigadores han
descubierto que las señales de picor de
la piel se transmiten a través de una
subclase de los nervios asociados con el
dolor
estos nervios producen una molécula
llamada polipéptido natriurético B que
desencadena una señal que va por la
médula espinal al cerebro donde crea la
sensación de picor
cuando nos rascamos la acción de
nuestras uñas en la piel causa una señal
de dolor de bajo nivel que anula la
sensación del picor es casi como una
distracción que crea la sensación de
alivio
Pero existe realmente un propósito
evolutivo para el picor o existe
simplemente para molestarnos la teoría
principal es que nuestra piel ha
evolucionado para ser agudamente
consciente al tacto nuestra respuesta de
rascado automática desalojaría cualquier
cosa perjudicial que esté potencialmente
al acecho sobre nuestra piel como una
picadura perjudicial un insecto
mordiente o los zarcillos de una planta
venenosa esto podría explicar por qué
nos sentimos picor por dentro como en
nuestros intestinos que están a salvo de
estas amenazas externas Aunque
imagínenlo enloquecedor que sería
en algunas personas la presencia de
problemas en las vías responsables de
todo esto puede causar picor excesivo
que incluso puede dañar su salud un
ejemplo extremo es una condición
psicológica llamada parásitos ilusorios
donde la gente cree que sus cuerpos
están infestados de ácaros o pulgas
corriendo sobre y bajo la piel y sienten
picor incesantemente
otro fenómeno llamado picor fantasma
puede ocurrir en pacientes que han
tenido amputaciones debido a que esta
lesión ha dañado gravemente el sistema
nervioso confunde la señalización
nerviosa normal del cuerpo y crea
sensaciones en los miembros que ya no
están
los médicos están encontrando maneras de
tratar estas anomalías de picazón en
amputados se usan espejos para reflejar
el miembro restante que el paciente se
rasca eso Crea una ilusión que engaña al
cerebro Para que sienta satisfacción por
el picor imaginario
curiosamente eso realmente funciona Los
investigadores también están buscando
los genes Implicados En el picor y están
desarrollando tratamientos para bloquear
el camino de una picazón en Casos
extremos si tener un picor inmanejable
parece algo propio de un infierno
personal Dante estuvo de acuerdo el
poeta italiano escribió sobre una
sección del infierno donde a la gente se
le aplicó el castigo de sentir picor por
toda la eternidad
Esta es otra pregunta que deseamos
profundamente indagar a fondo porque
soñamos Existe alguna razón evolutiva o
psicológica para ello resulta que en
realidad no lo sabemos pero tenemos
algunas teorías ve a este video para
averiguarlo